[Musique]
bienvenue sur le plateau date a dit
d'interdire on va passer toute cette
émission avec fabrice eps stein avocat
au barreau de paris et chroniqueur au
magazine rock and folk qui publie une
histoire judiciaire du rock intitulé
rocket dans le justice à la manifestion
du livre vous y revenez sur les les
jugements plus ou moins retentissant
d'ailleurs parce que beaucoup ne sont
pas connu un qui ont condamné où ils ne
sentaient les stars du rock dans tous
les domaines un plagiat drogue
escroquerie indécence blasphème
grossièreté incitations suicide à la
haine raciale ou meurtre mais commençons
tout de suite par l'image que vous avez
choisie pour illustrer notre époque
c'est celle ci
patti smith patti smith ou le panthéon
le semble-t-il derrière on le panthéon
octobre 2021
cette belle patti smith qui entrent dans
ce panthéon elle la punk rockeuse qui je
trouve envoie un message d'espoir de
beauté c'est ça aussi le rock mais
attendez kelly faiblesse qu'elle y
rentre pas comme nos je vais pin
baker et délirante vivante dans le cadre
des 50 ans de fip ouais elle pousse la
chansonnette
elle rend hommage à dylan elle cite un
de titres de dylan elle a toujours rendu
beaucoup d'hommages modeste c'est
toujours tout le monde exact mais en
cause que pour que ça vous paraît si
important tout à coup que patti smith ou
devant le panthéon le rock c'est plus ce
que c'était c'est de la variété
aujourd'hui c'est pas de la variété non
je trouve que ça à ça rend hommage au
rock ça rend hommage à cette musique et
ça montre aussi que l'europe peut entrer
dans un cadre peut-être un peu plus
constitutionnel ou un peu plus rigoureux
rigoriste et je trouve qu'elle a sa
place alors ce qu'on voit pas c'est que
à gauche il ya le drapeau français et le
drapeau de l'europe je trouvais jolie
qu'une américaine si fan de la france si
fan de rimbaud puisse aussi rendre
hommage à la france l europe recadre le
justice votre livre commence par la plus
célèbre affaire de plagiat de l'histoire
du rock on va ré écouter quelques
mesures de my sweet lord énorme tube de
george harrison après la séparation des
beatles écoutez
oh
[Musique]
non
les ronces et le
[Musique]
à l'époque donc c'est un énorme tube
tout le monde trouve ça très très joli
manque de bol ça a rappelé notamment pas
mal de gens un autre tube du début des
années 60 i saw fine parler chiffons
écouter
[Musique]
sofian n'avait été écrit et composé par
ronnie mac qui était noir qui était mort
mais il avait encore une maman qu'elle
pouvait pas ce que s'est passé que ces
plats grands comme tout à fait flagrant
harrison s'est fait attrapé très vite
finalement quand la chanson sort aux
états unis la succession ronnie mcl
attaque ils se retrouvent devant un
tribunal à new york et las ses avocats
font une petite erreur plutôt que de
choisir un jury populaire il décide un
juge unique manque de bol il tombe sur
un juge qui s'appelle owens qui est un
fana d'opéra et qui va tout de suite
dire que le plagiat évident mais il
emploie le terme de plagiat subconscient
et en fait harrison ça veut dire que
harrison l'a entendu qui ne se souvient
plus oui sauf que bon harrison n'a
entendu il le dit est bon plus tard les
9 un peu se moquer de lui en lui disant
tu sais tu aurais dû changer une deux
mesures et ça serait passé oui voilà
voilà mais alors là où cette affaire est
incroyable c'est qu'en fait celui qui va
bénéficier ou qui espère bénéficier
c'est le manager des beatles joué alors
là il ya une sorte de jeu un peu bizarre
entre le manager des beatles de l'époque
allen klein qui est aussi le manager
d'harrison ils sont assez proches il
tente un deal avec harrison pour lui
dire il a racheté les droits 10 au fine
et marc il se bat finalement contre
harrison il va avoir gain de cause mais
comme le juge a compris et cette espèce
d'astuces un peu bizarre et bien
il va condamner harrison mais un montant
très faible qui sera le montant des
droits d'acquisition de la chanson et
sauf a donc finalement c'est un peu
balle au centre mais allen klein qui
aimait les procédés avocat va réussir à
trouver une solution avec harrison ils
vont se partager la chanson l'un pour
les usa et l'angleterre l'autre pour le
reste de ce soit bien clair en fait
allen klein a racheté les droits de is
so fine exactement qu'en fait c'est à
lui que george harrisson devait de
l'argent
et pas aux héritiers de ronnie bac qui
malheureusement jamais ces clichés c'est
que vous n'êtes pas là le voilà allen
klein on va en reparler pascal aka il ya
un très très gros dossier inde en
rock'n'roll de justice mais d'abord un
autre cas malheureux intéressant de tout
plagiat
effectivement on va écouter tout de
suite man down the road chansons de john
fogerty qui sort dans les années 80 je
crois aux 85 voilà 85 john fogarty
c'était leader de creedence clearwater
revivent vol était le groupe qui avait
vendu quasiment le plus de disques en
1970 un nombre de numéros un combat la
dengue et l'oeil sur cette chanson dans
mon écoute
[Musique]
dit
plus
c'est un email
il se trouve que john fogerty qui était
un vrai génie il avait chanté des il
avait pondu un nombre de chansons
extraordinaire non on n'est plus depuis
un moment parce qu'il n'avait plus les
droits des chansons de de creedence et
c'est le celui qui détenait les droits
qui va porter plainte mais pour auto
plagiat c'est à dire qui va dire mais
attendait john fogerty là il est en
train de revendre une chanson qui
m'appartient à moi parce que je vais les
droits qui est écrite par fokker qui a
été écrite par fogerty mais c'est moi
qui ai les droits et qui s'appelle run
to the jungle c'est là tout le monde la
connaît on la réécoute et c'est vrai que
ça ressemble beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
lens
mais
[Musique]
en
l onu
ils ont souvent ces problèmes-là coup
parce qu'ils vendent leur catalogue en
fait c'est ça oui ils vendent leurs
catalogues ou soul dance à un peu
inspiré le catalogue de façon
intelligente c'est pas n'importe qui
sauf zen c'est le producteur de vol et
une élite coucou il manque pas d'argent
il a effectivement le catalogue fogerty
et quand fogerty qui en plus s'est
disputé avec ses anciens collègues on
lui reproche de passer trop de temps au
tribunal et pas assez en studio se
retrouve au tribunal collé par sundance
pour ces deux chansons on se demande si
auto plagiat finalement les juges disent
y'a pas auto plagiat ses chansons sont
différentes et en fait une autre
question se pose il va les différentes
au point de vue des notes elles sont
différentes oui le style et le même de
toute façon fogarty fait à peu près la
même chanson mais c'est ce que pas mal
de gens disent de certains groupes de
rock ils ont une chanson il la décline
sous différentes formes mais en tout cas
il s'en sort bien fogarty il n'est pas
condamné pour haute au plagiat et
surtout il ya une question qui se pose
c'est celle des frais d'avocat parce
qu'il a exposé énormément de frais
d'avocat il est en défense est
habituellement même si on gagne on ne
rembourse pas les frais d'avocat
quelqu'un qui a en défense et fogarty
traîne se laisse jusqu'à la cour suprême
et il a gain de cause et donc il obtient
une décision de la cour suprême 17
juillet c'est à dire que le rock fait
jurisprudence
souvent vous en raconter beaucoup le
colonel parker y les célébrissimes
c'était le manager d'elvis presley il
lui a fait signe et on les voit le jour
où il signe le contrat du siècle
pour parker pour parker effectivement
quoique en même temps elvis bas il
fallait le faire il en a fait la star
numéro un mais mais qu'est ce qu'on lui
reproche à la fin au colonel parker à
part qu'il a menti sur tout que ni les
images m'aperçois qu'à regarder la photo
le petit chien et le gros chien c'est
peut-être l'explication de leur relation
non mais qu'est ce qu'on lui reproche
d'être plus malin que tout le monde est
alors emmené le voir le colonel parker y
disait si vous voulez faire un deuxième
elvis alesi plus personne n'était
capable de faire ça c'est son seul
client
d'abord 25% des droits pour parker 25
ans en dérobant 50
dans son catalogue mais il a des idées
de génie parker il dit à elvis il faut
que tu fasses des films il faut que tu
chantes nantais fiel et après il en sort
des disques il fait des fortunes oui
mais ils lebel a de plus en plus haut
lieu samedi il lui a tué sa carrière
aussi way lui a tué sa carrière moi j'ai
l'impression que mon il est revenu aussi
un moment et parker derrière il
l'installé à las vegas c'était une bête
de cirque mais une bête de cirque qui
lui rapportait beaucoup qu'est ce qu'on
mérite
quand même obtenir ce que vous racontez
ils vont obtenir qu'on le conte le
dessaisisse les héritiers exactement ce
qu'est ce qui est fantastique c'est que
quand elle 10 meur évidemment il ya le
marchandising à tout ce qui va avec il
ya pas que la musique ils se disent on
va récupérer le pactole et finalement il
n'y a pas grand chose il ya le fisc qui
tarabuste la succession elvis et là il
ya une discussion entre rca parker et la
succession elvis pour qu'on réussisse à
sortir par coeur de saint laurent tout
et qui est encore dedans c'est à dire
qu'on va le payer pour qu'il s'en aille
le juge va tout de même dire que ça
choque jusqu'à la conscience humaine
donc on en est là bon parker part avec
son argent il meurt à las vegas dans un
hôtel on sait que c'est quand même le
sans papier le plus connu des états unis
parce qu'ils étaient hollandais la
quitter la hollande pour une histoire un
peu bizarre on sait pas très bien il a
quitté bréda un meurtre peut-être une
histoire avec une femme on n'en sait
rien il n'a jamais été naturalisé
américain
je suis même pas sûre de son vrai nom
nom s'est borné du jeu on sait pas troué
choses comme ça leur allen klein
puisqu'on l'a vu tout à l'heure lui il
est fabuleux allen klein parce qu'il
fait de hold up il fait sur les rolling
stones et sur les people oui il fait 2
et pas que sur les beatles donnent sur
harrison avec le concert pour le
bangladesh et ils traversent ce bouquin
c'est quelqu'un d'important c'est celui
de gauche 1 ou dans le rock cc voilà
déjà sept têtes avec cette pipe cette
façon de regarder on sent la malignité
disons les stones et d'ailleurs c'est le
manager des stones de l'époque à côté de
lui il se déroule durant exactement ils
ont besoin d'un bailleur de fonds il
retrouve ce monsieur ici une malle ma
mauvais contrats et aujourd'hui la
période 62 70 donc la période des cas
elle est entre les mains de ce monsieur
ou de sa succession et on ne peut rien y
faire c'est la vie quatre sont classées
les stones et ça va même plus loin parce
qu'après le groupe the verve reprend les
stones mais en fait tu reprends allen
klein toute une histoire il gagne à tous
les coups c'est le monopoly du rock avec
les beatles est un peu différent parce
que on veut y voir que du négatif il
leur a apporté des bonnes choses brian
epstein qui n'est pas de la même famille
que moi négocier pas toujours bien les
droits des beatles premier manager des
beatles exactement de liverpool allen
klein lui parfois ils négocient mieux
mais quand ils négocient mieux il en
prend plus pour lui c'est aussi sa façon
de se servir au passage et la fin des
beatles ça dure cinq ans quand même et
pendant cinq ans jusqu'en 75 il va
toucher au moins 20 ou 25% des recettes
des beatles et se poser comme alors
mccartney le détester lennon lui faisait
confiance harrison lui a même fait
confiance parce que quand il organise le
concert pour le bangladesh il passe par
lui ils récoltent des millionnaires
premier concert effectivement vous avez
raison à visée humanitaire avec l' app
tonnes avec dylan que des stars qui
jouent gratuitement 10 millions d'euros
10 millions de dollars par n'ont récolté
est en fait qu'ils n'arriveront pas
avant dix ans parce que ce monsieur qui
est un expert comptable a pas cocher la
bonne case dans la déclaration d'impôts
et l'argent reste aux états unis donc
ces gens qui meurent de faim ne touchent
même pas le fruit du travail d'harrison
jim morrison on va le voir en photo une
photo célèbre septembre 70 il est
derrière les barreaux qu'est ce qu'on me
reproche exactement alors là sûrement
autre chose que la terre ne sait même
pas certain que soit exactement la même
chose mais en tout cas la grande le
grand procès jim morrison c'est la 70ème
le concert à miami exactement cc 69 le
fameux concert à miami marc 69 il est
devant la foule il ya plus de billets
vendus c'est un peu le bordel il est
sous évidemment il invective il hurle et
il dit est ce que vous voulez la voir
alors après est-ce qu'il a accordée le
geste à la parole finalement on n'en
sait rien son pénis son pénis la chose
qui pend on n'en sait rien
il n'y a pas de photos elle est pas le
cas des téléphones portables y'a pas de
téléphone portable et chose finalement
ça c'est l'avocat que ça intéresse mais
même le justiciable il n'est pas
appréhendée tout de suite il se passe
quelques jours cinq jours plus tard dans
la presse on dit morrison a montré son
sexe c'est un scandale et c'est le
parquet s'en empare il est poursuivi
donc il va devant ce tribunal un an plus
tard il a la trouille de sa vie ce qui
n'a pas du tout envie qu'on lui coupe
les cheveux veut pas aller en prison et
là il est condamné alors il est condamné
pour exhibitionnisme pas pourri bresse
quand même étonnant parce qu'il était
saoul il le reconnaît lui-même et six
mois de prison infligée il fait appel il
part en france on connaît la suite il
meurt en france mais ça va un peu plus
loin c'est l'histoire et ça par exemple
je connaissais pas du tout mis à quai et
en un énorme fan de jim morrison en 2007
il est gracié parce qu'elle est fan de
jim morrison qui demande aux procureurs
de floride de le grâcier ya une
procédure et in fine il va être graciée
alors pour moi c'est un truc
complètement paradoxal il aurait dû très
vite et il aurait dû être acquitté
exactement mais le voilà graciée grâce à
dieu nous étions exactement gracié c'est
tout à fait ça ça veut dire que vous
avez commis des faits mais après vous
êtes gracié et bon finalement pour le
gouverneur de floride c'était un moyen
de se faire réélire il était au lycée
avec morrison
qui s'appelait christ john lennon
accusée de blasphème en 1966 on s'en
souvient tout le monde s'en souvient et
s'étaler alors ça on s'en souvient pas
ce que vous racontez c'est qu'en alabama
où l'histoire sort
suit cette fameuse interview de john
lennon qui explique que la religion
chrétienne va disparaître et que les
populaires beatles ont déjà plus
populaire que le christ ça fait scandale
en alabama où c'est pas des c'est pas
des tendres 1 c'est pas les
progressistes avant gardiste non plus et
il ya autodafé des disques des beatles c
est l époque on lui reproche mais pas
seulement d'un bonheur d'avoir blasphémé
oui alors moi je prend la défense de
lennon franchement qui voulait pas dire
quelque chose de trop choquant il a
interviewé au bout de sa vie cette vie
des beatles et de c'est dur pour lui
mais il pense que on se déchristianisée
que donc les beatles sont un peu d y
fier et il serait plus populaire oui
disent on est plus populaire que le
christ dans le sens il ya plus de gens
qui viennent nous voir que des gens qui
vont à l'église ce qui à mon avis était
assez vrai hélas à ça c'est ce qui va
expliquer la fin de leur concert tel
déversement de haine envers l'allemagne
nazie quoi on tire sur leur avion à
manille raviront contrat ça prend des
proportions pas possible il préfère
aller en studio tous les quatre que de
continuer cette vie de deux concerts ce
qui est rigolo c'est le vatican le
vatican s'est prononcée des années des
années après en disant mais finalement
lennon il était un peu paumé il a dit ça
il ne pensez pas mais pour nous les
beatles ça reste un groupe exceptionnel
bon voilà celui
qu'il avait sans doute pas tort mais non
ils avaient sans doute pas tort les
kings
groupe rock moins connus bien sûr que
les beatles mais mais mais adoré par les
paris ri culte second but des kings ses
deux frères les frères davies et eux ils
vont être carrément interdit de séjour
aux états unis pendant quatre ans oui
alors eu ces deux fous ils se disputent
tout le temps quand il discute pas entre
eux et se disputer avec les autres
membres du groupe ils partent aux états
unis ils sont mal manager on sent qu'il
va se passer quelque chose et un jour
sur un plateau un d un des frères davies
se dispute avec un cameraman il se
bagarre et finalement la la la guilde
des cameramans des états unis leur
demande de ne plus remettre les pieds
aux etats unis pendant quatre ans
indique à son puissant vous était très
puissant et est alors eux ils ont une
double lecture de la chose ils disent
non à côté comme on n'était pas bien
manager on n'a pas pu avoir autant de
succès que les beatles les stones ou
même les ou un qui ont vachement percer
aux etats unis de l'autre ils sont
revenus en angleterre ils ont fait leurs
grands tubes célébrant ses d'espèces
d'angleterre post break zut on revient à
nos valeurs villette green preservation
society c'est leur grand disque ils
l'auraient pas fait s'ils avaient eu 7
carats aux états unis mais ironie de
l'histoire ils sont quand même retourné
aux états unis et là ils ont rempli des
stades en faisant de la mauvaise musique
mais en remplissant les stan donc
finalement oui c'est un peu toujours la
même histoire les sexpistols ce le
groupe punk emblématique
sortent leur premier album et même
peut-être le seul
never mind the bollocks quand on est en
en
en 77 et l'été du punk ses 76 mais le
premier album ses 77 on va voir la
pochette never mind the bollocks quand
on le traduit ça veut dire on s'en bat
les couilles et donc les anglais
allaient enfin en angleterre ils sont
attaqués parce que il ya la décence
actes et c'est de la publicité indécente
on était pas on s'en bat les couilles et
ils vous gagnez alors oui ils vont
gagner ce qui est assez rigolo c'est que
eux en tant que tels ils sont pas
ennuyés c'est la maison de disques
fameux richard branson qui est derrière
eux qui les soutient et un revendeur qui
est dans le centre de londres avec un
énorme panneau never mind the bollocks
et on les embête sur le fondement de
cette indécence actes et là ils se
défendent de façon magistrale c'est à
dire que d'abord richard branson dit je
comprends pas moi j'ai vendu un million
de disques j'ai pas eu une réclamation
tout le monde trouve ça très bien
pourquoi vous demande été et ça va aller
plus loin que ça c'est que il prend
attache avec un professeur d'université
ils le font venir au tribunal alors ils
sont défendus par une espèce de star du
barreau qui s'appelle john brimmer qui
est écrivain également qui est un
personnage un peu à la simenon et lui
fait intervenir ce prof et ce prof
explique l'étymologie du mot bollocks et
là il surprend tout le monde en leur
disant que bollocks d'abord c'est une
petite chose c'est une orchidée aussi et
que souvent bollocks c'est un surnom
pour un prêtre pourquoi dit il au
tribunal parce que les prêtres disent
n'importe quoi donc voilà bollocks
conneries n'importe quoi il paraît que
les sex pistols fumait buvait dans le
tribunal de nottingham il ya un autre
argument vie assez intelligent c'est de
dire que le l'album a été recensée par
the guardian et un autre grand comédien
brésil et qui a pas de raison de ne pas
les traînées eux c'est vrai mais c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est vrai que font
l'apologie de cette pochette donc ils
ont leur place dans le box à côté des
autres finalement les traîne pas et
d'ailleurs ce que dit le prof c'est que
et l'avocat on a de la chance d'avoir
une anglaise aussi riche c'est ce qui
plaide les gagne john lennon et yoko ono
expulsés des états unis à cette époque
là on est en 72
61 à la fin c'est l'époque où
véritablement il attire les
photographies sont dans la protestation
continue elle dans le ligne anti guerre
du vietnam et vous dites que c'est
richard nixon qui adoucissent est dans
le deuil qui a les notes d'enlever les
notes et anglais et les japonaises on
les expulse ou alors ils tentent elles
tendent parce qu'ils vivent à new york
yoko ono a des attaches à new york elle
un premier enfant lennon tombe fou
amoureux de new york city lille i et i
les protestataires c'est à dire que
dès qu'ils se mêlent de quelque chose il
ya un problème ça nique sonne ne
supporte pas il le suit et surtout il
veut le faire sortir des états unis il
s'appuie sur quoi il notera fait entre
on va parler le fait qu'à un moment 68 à
londres lennon a été retrouvé avec de la
drogue chez lui on en parle on en
reparlera donc voilà nixon tente de le
mettre dehors et là c'est très drôle
parce que lennon veut un avocat en
immigration spécialisés et on lui
fournit un type qui s'appelle les all
whites ils le rencontrent c'est un
avocat juif qui parlent dit dis-je qui
ne connaît absolument pas lennon et
quand ils rencontrent les neuf il dit
j'ai rencontré jack lemmon il voit
vraiment pas comment ces îles et il est
tout à fait perdu mais bon il commence à
intéresser au dossier il trouve qu'il ya
ailleurs dit pardon une chose me plaît
pas pendant shabbat parce que je réponde
à sa maison parce que vous racontez ce
qu'il faut dire c'est que les dogues à
l'époque il prend la tête de tout à tout
le monde tous sont de 6 soit là si on a
affaire à lennon c'est qu'il va vous
bombardez de ceux ci c'est un client
quand on est avocat on sait ils
bombardent les clients sont toujours là
et en fait il va trouver pas mal
d'arguments ce fameux lien weitz
notamment qu' on a trouvé de la résine
de cannabis chez lennon mais que c'est
pas de la drogue en tant que tel selon
le code américain donc déjà une première
faille et ensuite il va réussir à
montrer que le dossier de lennon il est
aux oubliettes avec pas mal d'autres
dossiers et ça ça va faire plier
l'administration américaine et
finalement elle va pas avoir d'autre
choix que de donner à lennon sa green
card le jour de son anniversaire et
d'ailleurs je crois que la carte et bleu
elle n'est pas du tout green c'est à
dire aller et ça a profité à d'autres
qui était dans une situation à laquelle
expulsion ou s'ils ont été régularisés
par obama plus tard oui parce que
justement on les avait un peu oublié on
les laisse la pourrir ouais y'a le
groupe judas priest on va voir une photo
du chanteur qui a été accusé d'avoir
poussé deux jeunes gens au suicide c'est
le chanteur de judas priest
ça c'est un vrai et c'est un truc de fou
d'ailleurs ça a donné lieu à un
reportage sur arte qui est assez génial
où on voit le procès puisque le procès
est filmé
ils font une chanson dans laquelle on
peut entendre de façon subliminale il
faut se bouger un truc qui dit do it
sous-entendu fait le il ya de fait les
disons de jeunes qui sont pas très très
bien dans leurs bottes aux états unis
qui décide de se tuer inspiré par la
chanson les jeux de l'esprit est une a
un qui meurt et l'autre qui est à deux
doigts de la mort mais qui peut suivre
son procès les familles décident
d'attraire jodas priest aux états unis
en disant c'est de l'incitation au
suicide et on va retrouver ces messieurs
avec les cheveux longs leurs tenues en
train de se justifier et d'expliquer que
finalement d'abord il n'y a pas de
message subliminal g faut prouver
l'existence d'un message subliminal
c'est pas simple et ensuite que
finalement c'était pas de l'incitation à
au suicide et qu' ils avaient leur libre
arbitre et qui aurait pu ne pas tuer ils
vont avoir gain de cause mais ça va
donner lieu dans cette petite ville de
reno on l'a on n'est pas loin de las
vegas c'est un peu paumé à un procès
assez hors norme pour montrer jusqu'où
cette musique là peut avoir de
l'influencé sur la mesure d'ailleurs des
procès oui avec hadji aux normes aussi
minutieusement leader de black sabbath
être également poursuivi et l'histoire
des messages subliminaux ça aussi ça
accompagne j'ai l'impression l'histoire
du rock ou des toujours persuadé
dans les pocher on dans les pochettes
combat si on écoute discale en va
exactement une sorte de truc oui oui
parce que c'est un lieu un monde dans
lequel le mythe arrive rapidement comme
john lennon avait pas tort au fond
rhodia il ya eu la religion du rock oui
oui et la religion
d'ailleurs là on a épluché les textes
et les images comme on les a épluché en
ce qui concerne les religions oui c'est
vrai qu'il ya un côté un peu mais ce
parfois et c'était aussi le sens de la
photo de patti smith ont elles un côté
prêtresse elle ouvre les bras elle
parle à son public s'il y a ça dans le
rock aussi on fait une pause fabrice
abstenez on se retrouve juste après vous
avez encore plein d'histoires nous
raconter
[Musique]
l'invité date a dit interdire
aujourd'hui est avocat et chroniqueur au
magazine rock n folk c'est fabrice stein
qui est avocat je les dis et qui publie
rock'n roll justice une histoire
judiciaire du rock à la manufacture du
livre la liste de picture alors
aujourd'hui on l'a oublié mais à
l'époque elle a eu un retentissement
considérable qui était pictures cet
homme qu'on va voir en photo là qui
vient d'arrêter ses lequel des deux
pitcher's gauche celui de gauche et il
vient d'arrêter john lennon chez lui et
c'est pas le premier qu'il arrête un il
avait arrêté d'havana van vyve jagger et
keith sweat shops et marianne faithfull
et il arrêtera encore ensuite
alors boscéens c'était une star à
l'époque c'était une star de la police
de la police tv parce que il faisait un
truc incroyable cob en cui jian dans la
soif du mal d'orson welles c'était un
sale flic il allait chez ces stars là il
mettait de la drogue pour la plupart les
hypothèses certains n'avaient mais en
tout cas il en mettait pour une cure de
l'adouber exactement il les a arrêtés
avec les caméras et d'appeller avait des
caméras partout il y avait des caméras
partout il par exemple la lennon il est
chez ringo starr et il sait que pilcher
va descendre donc il fait en sorte de
ratisser tous il n'y a pas il reste rien
du tout et lui réussi à mettre de la
drogue et à les arrêter alors sa chute
elle et elle arrive et finalement été
assez jeunes ce qui est étonnant c'est
qu'il n'est pas il a 10 ans de plus que
toutes ces stars du rock et sa volonté
c'était de se faire remarquer il y là
faut témoigner il a fait un faux
témoignage dans le cadre d'un procès ça
lui a valu huit même d'être
suivis dans le cadre d'un procès d'être
condamné il s'exile en australie on l'a
fait revenir il était en prison il a
vécu oublier ensuite et il est mort sans
personne ne sache qui il était mais à
l'époque cdd dès sa retentissante d'âme
quand quand on arrête de mick jagger
keith wiggans tas et marianne faithfull
racontant que marianne faithfull on l'a
trouvé nu rouler dans une fourrure alors
ça ça un énorme retentissement ils vont
en taule pendant plusieurs jours les
deux frères ricciardo et jagger bon ça
fait aussi leurs affaires parce qu'ils
sortent maintenant ils vont être
défendue par les grands journaux anglais
devront être défendus par les grands
journaux anglais et dans la photo de
couverture de livia se allen klein qui
est derrière qui sourit oui c'est vrai
qu'il faut bien que ça va lui rapporter
gros c'est au moment de au moment du
jugement quand exactement quand ils ont
ils ont été c'est la couverture de votre
livre
la mention
explicit lyrics
voilà celle là aujourd'hui on n'y fait
plus attention elle fait surtout les cds
mais comment est elle née en fait
c'était la fab exhale d'or existe encore
leur bord quelques dates
d'ouverture entendent par là
effectivement plus odieux une vraie dame
de vertus et les coudes prins avec sa
fille elle se dit mon dieu mais que dit
il c'est absolument horrible il faut
pouvoir contrôler cette musique et
contrôler le hard rock et tout ce qui
est au goût du jour dans les années 80
90 85 sous x 3 mais je en tout cas où 85
86 et elle va mon à inciter l'industrie
musicale qui se couche en grande partie
comme
pour qu' il y ait un symbole sur les
disques donc elle elle crée un truc
c'est le pm rcc une association pour que
les enfants est une vue de l'esprit plus
clair qu'ils soient protégés etc et elle
va réussir à faire qu' il y ait ce
parental advisory explicit lyrics alors
il y à une audition du sénat qui
ressemble un peu à cette mission kieffer
qui avait été la mission pour les
mafieux un truc très sérieux d'où
viennent témoigner des gens pas trop
sérieux ou en tout cas qui se prennent
pas au sérieux il ya frank zappa qui
vient on va le voir
ce qui se passe dans cette enceinte
c'est un truc digne de l'allemagne nazie
il ya d'autres artistes voilà il est un
jour
il a l'air vraiment circonspect parce
qu'il peut lire pour ce united tc net
ils sont entendus finalement on applique
cette mention et ironie de l'histoire
mais c'est assez évident ça fait la
sphère de l'industrie musicale puisqu'on
vend beaucoup plus avec cette mention
que sans cette mention et voilà madame
tipper gore qui est prise à son propre
piège finalement interdit d'interdire en
tout cas voilà interdire ça même pas
toujours en moyenne 10% de plus de
ventes et surtout les rappeurs oui les
rameurs et lorsque d'europe est obligé
d'avoir ça c'était l'autocollant
tous les tricheurs tous les produits
dérivés avec ce signe que les gens
portent et ça apporte énormément
d'argent à l'industrie chiffre est
évidemment
bob dylan a été mis en examen en france
en 2012 pour assise on le voit le jeu ça
c'est quand il avait reçu la victoire
c'est à ce moment là est évident gr
aujourd'hui pas le jeu il et il est mûr
d'examiner récitation la haine raciale
et et injures publiques
pour une interview incroyable où elle
est complètement incroyable ses fans
absolus de dylan c'est une histoire que
j'ai découverte un peu au hasard et en
2011 je crois ça fait longtemps qu'il
n'a pas pris la parole et il parle à
rolling stone usa dans un très long
article est belle de bleu baguette
magazine pardon dylan unleashed et dit
tout et là on lui demande où pensez quoi
de la société américaine aujourd'hui et
diva société américaine elle est rongé
par ses démons l' esclavage les noirs
les blancs quand vous êtes noir vous
chantez quelqu'un qui a du sens du ku
klux klan quand vous êtes juif vous
chantez le sens d'un nazi et quand vous
êtes serbe vous chantez le sens d'un
croate que n'at-il pas dit aux états
unis tout bon sens mais tout le monde
s'en fout complètement
rolling stone us à un correspondant en
france les rolling stones france à
magazine complètement indépendants ils
font paraître l'article de dylan et l'a8
a traduit en français s'offusque le
comité représentatif des croates de
france de concert présenté des
comportements et
ah sing faye porte plainte contre eux
dylan pas ce qu'il a dit que voilà ils
sont six exactement donc là ils se
disent de quoi il parlait ce que c'est
les oustachis est-ce que passer c'est
en
gros sauf que lui il avait dit pour dire
que les croates étaient victimes des
serbes bleu et blanc du gala il y avait
tout un une discussion pour savoir ce
qu'il avait dit lui même se réfugier
derrière le fait qu'il était un poète en
france c'est quasi automatique cette
mise en examen et dylan il est courageux
il vient en france il se fait remettre
la légion d'honneur il fait de concert
et ils passent par le palais de justice
à l'île de la cité on a quand même remis
la légion d'honneur à 10 l'aide alors
qu'il était
mis en examen et à voir la légion
d'honneur même être condamné imaginer
voir la légende aujourd'hui peut-être
peut-être en tout cas voilà il va devant
le juge il est mis en examen il est
super bien défendu évidemment le
magazine rolling stone haussier très
bien défendu l'argument dylan il est
tout simple il dit moi aux rolling
stones france le magazine connaît pas
jamais lu je savais pas que ça existait
moi ce que j'ai dit c'est dans rolling
stone usa donc maintenant vous
débrouiller et le jugent effectivement
est obligé finalement de
lui donner un non-lieu rolling stones
france est poursuivie devant la 17e
chambre correctionnelle et ils s'en
sortent pour des questions de procédure
alors sa petite ironie de l'histoire
pour le conseil décroît de france leur
objet social de l'association il est
trop large pour pouvoir attrait en
justice dylan et rolling stones et il a
quand même été écrit par un prof de
droit comme fois sélectionne pas
toujours les mieux fossé toujours en
france cédées on voit bien les procès en
france
élite et donc en france également
clapton a des problèmes pour un vieil
album bon qu'il avait écrit pour cette
jeune femme pattie boyd qui était à
l'époque la fameuse la judge harrison il
l'appelle leïla dans le disque il était
fou amoureux d'elle mais c'était la
femme de son copain ils ne seront
ensemble que quelques années plus tard
et il a le disque on va en voir la
pochette est un disque extrêmement
célèbres que de signe pas clapton
d'ailleurs il le site d rect domino et
puis en 2000 à 40 ans plus tard et aux
écarts entre fred qui sort avec la même
poche est cette pochette elle avait été
panne par franck scène ils avaient
utilisé ce tableau la jeune fille au
bouquet
ça j'avais posé de problème mais quand
sans le coffret tout avait tout a fini à
dix et c'est dénaturer et par ailleurs
dans le coffret c'est vrai que l'image
était un peu du bo3 défunt moyer une
dénaturation selon elle donc elle
considère que ça respecte pas l'esprit
de l'oeuvre de son père alors c'est
compliqué parce que le tableau a pas été
donné par elle mais par le fils naturel
de son père quand clapton squatté à
valbonne et repart avec qui trouvent
qu'il le tableau est beau après c'est
son goût il n'en fait cette fameuse
pochette de disque quarante ans plus
tard il attaqué mais dis-moi débrouillez
vous bon tout imbroglio judiciaire il ce
qui est rigolo c'est qu'on a un clapton
à la cour de cassation française on a un
arrêt avec clapton bon finalement il en
sort plutôt bien plutôt indemne et daft
punk
contre la sacem ouais la sacem
normalement c'est la meilleure copine de
tous les musiciens est censé nous leur
vie dans le monde entier la grande
protectrice moi je dis que c'est le plus
froid des monstres froids pour
paraphraser nietzsche
et de récupérer vos droits versés des
rucks et les plus intelligents en tout
cas comme ça que j'ai considère quand
ils vont à la sacem ils disent on veut
pas que vous gériez tous nos droits
certain nombre de droits qu'on veut
gérer nous-mêmes et la sacem leur dit
non ça marche pas c'est tout ou rien bon
et considère que c'est pas la bonne
façon ils prennent un super avocat ils
vont devant la commission européenne
parce qu'il considère que la sacem elles
sont et en position d'abus dominante que
les statuts doivent être changées et
finalement ils réussissent faire plier
la sacem les statuts change et
la pratique de l'écrémage donc on met un
peu ce combat la sacem ça marche grâce
aux daft punk aujourd'hui peut-être un
tout petit peu de contexte un des deux
bangs altère son père lui en avait gros
après la sacem parce qu'ils considèrent
que pendant la deuxième guerre mondiale
un certain nombre de droits d'auteur ont
pas été versés à des artistes juifs donc
thomas bangalter il a été un peu élevés
dans ce truc la ville soit exactement si
sacem méfions-nous
chic berry vous n'en parlez pas mais je
tenais à ce qu'ils soient présents parce
que dieu sait s'il y en a un qui a eu
maille à partir avec la justice toutes
les stars noires en général c'est fini
ont maille à partir avec la justice lui
particulièrement l époque est une
immense star chuck berry et il est
arrêté deux fois il va quand même passé
vingt mois en prison 20 ans en prison
alors que c'est une star énorme parce
que au début des années 60 pour
infraction à la loi man qui était loi de
1910 et et qui interdisait à de faire
passer une frontière entre deux états
aux états unis à une jeune femme pour la
prostituée et cette loi très souvent il
faut s'en servir contre les stars noires
et sens de la musique et notamment chuck
berry qui avait engagé une fille enfin
il l'avait rencontrée il ya proposé du
boulot dans un de ces dans un de ces
bars et il lui fait passer la frontière
pas au fond du ces pour la prostituée cc
je vais dans votre sens parce que il ya
eu un chapitre sur jerry lewis et on
voit que c'est une infraction à lui tout
seul et que finalement ils passent pas
beaucoup de gens en prison il ya des
trucs absolument horrible mais il est
blanc il est blanc
blanc comme une injustice berry c'est
dingue james bond ça va être pareil j'ai
besoin il a quand même commis quelques
quelques dopent quand il met pas des
méchants old barry white aussi oui voilà
mais je crois que vous pourriez écrire
un livre entier sur les shows les
chanteurs noirs on est d'accord un tome
2 - en bas qui ont eu maille à partir
avec la justice et comment l expliquez
vous qu'il ait pas encore eu de mitu du
rock parce que imaginer le nombre petit
groupe i qui pourrait dire aujourd'hui
accusés d'aider rockstar d'avoir été de
les avoir violées il ya vingt ans il y
aurait des chanteurs d'opéra accusée par
des femmes 40 ans après et pas de stars
du rock moi dit on peut croire ou penser
que ça va venir
oui sa réfection des plats et est-ce que
c'est du rock c'est un autre sujet de
débat marilyn manson on lui reproche des
choses même dylan jeu récemment il ya eu
une polémique autour d'une groupie très
jeune que lui dit avoir aidé qu'elle dit
avoir été abusé il n'y a pas plus de
choses aujourd'hui elle a porté plainte
un jour avant la prescription de de son
affaire donc non gageons que les
affaires arriveront oui alors elles sont
arrivés massivement dans leurs habits
oui c'est vrai rue dans le rap bien sûr
non la voc le plus célèbre étant tupac
bien surtout pas qu'il ya quand même
fait onze mois à rikers island braakhuis
prison absolument le fameux pénitencier
qu'on a appris à connaître au moment où
dominique strauss kahn il ya été d
exactions lui lui oui nous d'eux mêmes
et même si tu vis chasse le bassiste des
sex pistols c'est
que lui il y a passé 11 mois et parce
qu'il avait été accusé d'abus sexuels
par une de ses fans exactement qui
venait lui rendre visite dans un hôtel
pour lui vis de courtoisie pour elle
passa en tout cas elle dit avoir été
abusé
il a été condamné c'est à ce moment là
d'ailleurs ou chaudes night
son futur manager a pris contact avec
lui où il se retrouve dans son écurie et
plus tard des choses dont je parle dans
ce bouquin c'est savoir qu'il a tué ça
reste un immense mystère
beaucoup beaucoup de soupçons pèsent sur
son manager pour des histoires de gros
sous la police de los angeles qui est
une des plus corrompus du monde on
l'avait déjà vu avec l école de langues
une des plus violentes
a priori et en lien avec cette affaire
bon si je trouve ça vraiment dommage que
que l'on puisse pas avoir le fin mot de
l'histoire
il ya eu beaucoup de documentaires sur
nos questions château mais bon voilà il
serait ce un se prénomme en soldes ça
veut tout dire pas jusqu'à présent
vraiment on n'a pas aurait ajouté
question vous aborder aussi dans ce
livre c'est qu'est ce qu'un groupe parce
que les rolling stones les beatles
est-ce que c'est une entreprise est ce
que oui c'est surtout parce que la
question se pose dès qu'il sait pas où
est la question non mais c'est vrai la
voile et les pink floyd il vaut se
diviser en deux oui alors l'équilibré de
l'épi la question vous la vie aurait pu
se poser pour brian jones quand mick
jagger et keith richards décide de virer
by jones qui est le fondateur du groupe
à quel titre peuvent encore le faire la
même façon que les pink floyd ont viré
syd barrett qui est le fondateur du
groupe qui a trouvé le nom du groupe c
de bluesman nord de prénom pink floyd
bon ils n'auront rien laisser assez de
bluesman pour aller chercher ça voulait
dire flamants roses aussi mais chercher
ce nom bon pour waters pink floyd c'est
waters pour les autres c'est l'entité
quand en 85 87 ça commence à une plus
fonctionner il ya un certain nombre de
procès waters gagne pour que les pink
floyd restant n'utilise pas le nom et
perd ensuite et gilmour wright et mason
réussi ça a continué à être pink floyd
finalement c'est le public qui décide
parce que personne ne va voir water son
concert quand il est seul à cette époque
là mais continue d'aller voir les pink
floyd la question se pose encore plus
loin après c'est que en amérique du sud
il ya des gens qui font des engrais qui
s'appelle pink floyd et on leur dit non
non vous pouvez pas utiliser ça parce
que finalement même si pink floyd a pas
déposer la marque donc ce n'est pas une
marque il ya une telle confusion dans
l'esprit du public que vous pouvez pas
vous servir de ce nom donc c'est rien du
tout mais c'est aussi une entreprise
little et créé apple corporacion ils ont
même un problème est qu apple
il ya il ya des lettres d'avocats et
lettres de okah qui fusilla yaoi aimé
mais parce que c'est une entreprise il
faut la dissoudre si on veut que chacun
reparte avec ses petits
way cci on est obligé à un moment de
judiciariser la chose de prendre des
protocoles et de six mois j'ai mangé un
groupe
de bas et je vais revoir oui vous me
conseillez quoi on fera une société il
faut alors le groupe en tant que tel
sera pas une société mais les membres du
groupe détenir un certain nombre de
choses les droits des chansons le
catalogue le merchandising etc faut que
ce soit exploité par une société avec un
beau pacte d'actionnaires et et à ce
moment là où ce salary donc on pourrait
salariés oui si c'est vrai que ça peut
être la logique était fausse allait
d'ailleurs c'est par ailleurs tout c'est
le même salaire d'ailleurs on pourrait
estimer la vaut plus que l'autre ouais
effectivement mais d'ailleurs c'est le
début avec ennui c'est le début des
ennuis mots il faut il faut se mettre à
table avec de mon avocat va essayer du
moins c'est mal commencé il va coller
tous ces jeunes gens qui ont
révolutionné la musique dans les années
soixante dix avec tous 20 21 22 ans on
comprend qu'ils soient tous faits mais
absolument tous offert un match parce
que parce que finalement c'est une
question de milieu et de naissance les
doors on pourrait penser que ils sont
fait escroquer et bien robby krieger le
père était un businessman il avait un
super copain avocat il le remet dans les
pattes le max fink l'avocat du groupe
négocie tout de façon extrêmement
équitable donc c'est aussi être changé
vic jagger qui est très hâte de lui
avait fait la london oui le fait que des
musulmans quand même très longtemps avec
papy s'est fait arnaquer dans les
grandes largeurs là il a rien compris il
a mis dix ans à comprendre quand il a
compris il a bien compris n'aurait plus
besoin de lui expliquer
exactement et la bouche et voilà
ailleurs même ça ils l'ont très bien
négocié jeudi dans le livre c'était un
appel à des jeunes designers cette
fameuse bouche ils n'ont pas acheté
grand chose jouer reconnaît l'auteur de
la bouche il n'a rien touché très peu
glauque et ils ont compris après ils ont
bien compris ils ont compris comment il
faut attaquer les
jeunes et après pas de vieillesse se
mettraient en jeunesse et il y en a un
qui est en prison aujourd'hui pour
meurtre c'est phil spector il est même
mort en prison ah c'est vrai il est vrai
qu'entre temps il est mort il est mort
depuis c'est vrai il est mort il est
rentré en prison 69 ans spector on le
voit sur cette photo une tête de fou bon
cela dit au moment où au moment d'un
tribunal on n'a jamais l'air très
nombreux mais phil spector ç'avait été
un vrai génie quand il était très jeune
et il a été le plus jeune producteur à
faire des tubes ou des bises et 67
extraordinaire après il est devenu
vraiment infréquentable toutes les stars
du rock ensuite qui ont travaillé avec
lui ont eu deux cibles m mais vraiment
il vit avec une arbalète il tirait sur
tout le monde et puis finalement ça a
dégénéré puisque il était accusé du
meurtre d'une jeune femme exacte et
premier premier procès le procès devrait
tomber d'accord finalement il ya un
doute savoir si c'est elle se serait
suicidée en tout cas c'était à lui c'est
qu'elle avait pris le pistolet
l'ex-recteur c est ce que parce que lui
avait dans son salon évidemment 5,6
pistolet il sera armé et surarmés il les
collectionne l adorer ça il dit qu'elle
s'est suicidée qu'elle était au bout de
sa vie qu'elle n'avait pas réussi dans
le monde des actrices en tout cas elle
était mécontente de son existence et
qu'elle s'est suicidée évidemment on
peut penser linverse s'il persévère
quelques femmes qui ont dit que c'était
il est
il avait une personnalité absolument
ignobles puisque même quand il avait
enregistré avec leonard cohen leonard
cohen maître zen qui lui aussi s'est
fait arnaquer pas par phil spector ne
pouvait pas supporter d'une telle
violence et folie et les beatles ont le
paul mccartney lui on a toujours voulu
d'avoir mis ses horribles violence
inouïe mais bon après une discussion en
moi je trouve que dans une longue et
noah ni gros ni l'on vend ça pleure leur
place mais bon voilà en tout cas
deuxième procès il est condamné il est
en prison depuis fin il était en prison
pendant longtemps c'est le producteur le
mieux payé en prison qui continuaient de
toucher des royalties
aujourd'hui la l'honneur de tous et un
féminicide est-ce qu'on doit arrêter
d'écouter ses disques parce que c'est
une petite question qu'on peut se poser
mais il l'aurait fait tellement en tant
que producteur les gens savent pas que
c'est maintenant l'heure par exemple
harrison ressort son fameux all things
must pass
c'est specter derrière tout est specter
ouais il était l'inventeur du wall of
sound mais au fond des meurtres il y en
a beaucoup qui vont être victimes
notamment marvin gaye a tué par son père
mais par son bob marley ouais mais il y
en a peu qui ont été en prison pour
meurtre
oui parce que il n'y a pas eu finalement
énormément de moeurs qui est plutôt de
l'indécence de l'exhibition en tout cas
une volonté de choquer de fer ancien
société des meurtres peut-être plus dans
le hard rock ou dans le rap mais dans le
rock finalement musique assez sages de
ce point de vue-là oui enfin pas pour
l'époque mais bien des progrès à la
lumière de ce qui a pu se passer se
produire ensuite on peut se dire qu'il
était assez gentil vous notez d'ailleurs
que on a fait des procès pour apologie
du suicide enfin pour incitation au
suicide on n'a jamais fait de procès
pour incitation
pour apologie de la drogue oui oui ces
valeurs qu'il ya énormément de chansons
qui sont célèbres pour en faire
l'apologie justement et que ça n'est
jamais là on les a arrêtés pour
possession c'est vrai mais jamais pour
essayer de rendre peut-être parce que
les les textes qui existaient à l'époque
aux états unis était pas
ne s'accordaient pas avec les situations
que pas mal de chansons était codé enfin
c'est les gentils code qui se retrouvait
assez facilement qu'il y avait un doute
eu parfois et s'était même pas coder on
les imaginait oui oui exactement et non
il y avait aussi cette volonté de la
jeunesse de connaître des choses
différentes et puis la drogue n'a pas eu
des effets négatifs des effets positifs
aussi de dépassement de soi castaneda
c'est quand même quelqu'un qui a mis au
goût du jour
la recherche de soi on est énergique des
dalles et on était à la porte dans la
percée exactement on était dans une
recherche ou et cc on était vraiment
dans dans une recherche un peu de
l'autre de deux choses nouvelles et la
drogue a aidé finalement le l'on dit que
la country est une réalité et une
musique qui parle beaucoup plus de
drogues et d'alcool que le rock est
d'ailleurs la conterie ça se finit très
souvent mal parce que les chansons
racontent des histoires de gens qui ont
vu qu'ils sont seuls qui ont été
larguées tu sais que parfois elle se
suicider tu que le rock il reste un
message positif et supprimer le seul
d'ailleurs qu'un des grands auteurs
compositeurs un dieu sait si ces
chansons ont été reprises par tout le
monde il est il vient de la country le
départ lui il essaye de lui là une
grande croisade pour libéraliser le
cannabis finalement faire un peu
d'argent passage aussi parce qu'il crée
son entreprise au moins bien que les
superstars tu peur de ce secteur mais
c'est rigolo parce qu'il se fait arrêter
avec de la drogue évidemment et
finalement il est mal jugé ou pas je
gêne on revient peut-être à votre
réflexion sur les noirs et les blancs
parce que il n'a pas été appréhendé dans
les
conditions de la loi et donc il ya un
vice de procédure ça serait peut-être
paris 27 berry ça en écrivant ce livre
ou vos chroniques de rock and folk vous
avez été étonné et très sûr j'imagine
toujours l'europe qui effectivement
comme commun une histoire jalonnée de
procès de oui oui en prison je savais
qu'il y avait des procès je connaissais
quelques procès mais j'ignorais dylan
par exemple une incitation à la haine
j'ignorais aussi que dylan était aussi
cité dans les décisions de justice
américaine c'est à dire que les juges
américains en californier quand ils
veulent remettre une partie à sa place
ici dylan à la cour suprême ont si dylan
sage l'ignoré complètement et puis j'ai
un scoop dans ce livre c'est un petit
scoop avec qui date des années 68 c'est
que george harrison qui est quand même
il revient beaucoup dans ce livre parce
que je je l'aimais beaucoup c'est mon
people préférés disons il s'est battu
avec un photographe annie ce qui
s'appelle ben hebert et
on a la photo de ben hebert qui le prend
avant qu'il se batte puisque c'est parce
qu'il a été pris en photo à la forêt qui
s'est battu avec lui et il a été renvoyé
devant le tribunal correctionnel de nice
pour coups et blessures et je trouve
cette histoire assez assez génial et
insolite donc on apprend des choses j'ai
appris des choses et il n'y a pas eu de
le procès des beatles on aurait pu
imaginer un moment c'était pas loin il
aurait pu swiss oz ils sont tellement à
couteaux tirés paul mccartney d'un côté
les trois autres beatles de l'eau oui
oui moi d'ailleurs je trouve qu'on
compte qu'on le voit pas mal dans get
back alors j'ai pas tout vu un jeu free
planète dans le film qui vient de sortir
où tout le monde dit c'est fantastique
il aimait être ensemble
premier épisode c'est pas tout à fait
sage on ressent harrison qui en a
ras-le-bol on ressent ringo starr qui
est pas là lennon il est dans une autre
planète il est déjà en cette politique
m'a carnet c'est de faire le chef bon
c'est oui on aurait pu imaginer un
procès retentissant pour des droits avec
un peu plus de 2
200 disons mais les beatles ont les
beatles à reste des bons garçons on peut
dire ça
merci fabrice m steyn rock'n'roll
justice ça vient de paraître à la
magnifique tueur du livre vous allez on
fera sur les noirs je t'en faire ces
spams et des pères est absolument plus
épais sur bus ont rajouté le jazz à vous
ferez l'introduction les jazzmen les
pauvres qu'est ce qu'ils ont subi enfin
bref le livre est sorti elle avait dû
facture du livre merci de nous est
d'avoir passé tout ce temps avec nous
merci de nous avoir suivis et rendez
vous au prochain numéro
[Musique]